اذا نحن اا هنا في درب لوسيل في استوديو
الجزيره الخاص لتغطيه مباريات كاس العالم
والمباراه الختاميه احمد الجاسم متواجد
ايضا في درب الوسيه احمد لاحظنا ان هناك
استعدادات فضلا عن الاجواء الاحتفاليه
لاحظنا ان هناك استعدادات
لفعاليه ستقام ما الذي سيحصل في درب
الوسيل بعد تتويج الفريق الارجنتيني بكاس
العالم
بالفعل جلال
جماهير الارجنتين بالتوابل الى درب الحسين
لحضور الاحتفالات
المصاحبه لفوز المنتخب الارجنتيني همم
الالعاب الناريه الحركه هنا في درب الحسين
كما ترون وتشاهدون الجماهير المرتضى درب
الوسيل يعتبر بوابه العبور من ست الى هنا
جميع جماهير اا سعيده بفوز الارجنتين معظم
الجماهير التي لديه هنا من مشجعين المنتخب
الارجنتيني همم
الفوز اليوم همم الصراحه كانت المباراه
كاس العالم
واشكر الدوله على التنظيم
واا
بالتوفيق طبعا جلال بعد تتويج المنتخب
الارجنتيني في استاد الحسين سيتحرك سيتحرك
حافله المنتخب الارجنتيني الى هنا حيث
ابقى اااه
لمشاركه الاحتفالات مع الجماهير الاف او
البيئات الالاف من الجماهير هنا تحتفل
بفوز المنتخب الارجنتيني همم الاجواء بشكل
عام جدا جدا جدا حماسيه
فلسطين فلسطين
الحمد لله بطوله انصفت ميسي قبل ان تنصف
منتخب الارجنتين من فتره طويله ونتيجه
مقاربه لنتيجه الثائر اللي في عام 2018
نحمد الله على الفوز ونشكره انصف ميسي
بطوله انصافته من فتره طويله
بالتوفيق بالتوفيق طبعا جميع الجماهير انا
بعيده بفوز الارجنتين
فعاليات الالعاب الناريه فعاليات
الحضور المنتخب الارجنتيني لتتويجا
فعاليات المسير العسكري الذي سيحدث في
الدقائق القليله القادمه هذا ما لدينا
جلال ادعي لك في الاستديو